even Democrats in Florida are realizing
how good we got it unfortunately the
Democratic party of Florida has been in
a semi-conscious coma for a long period
Now read the script and I don't think a
week out that's going to do much if
anything whatsoever I mean think of
what's going on as far as the messaging
Florida's been hitting on all cylinders
immediately disconnect Stern's
microphones and I'm a Democrat telling
you this what a Floridian is concerned
about they're concerned about inflation
they don't pin that to the current
Administration in Florida they pin that
to Washington to the Democratic party
they're concerned about immigration
they're concerned about crime think
about what's going on in our country
right now people are getting mugged
they're getting mugged on the city
streets but they're also getting mugged
when they go to the grocery stores turn
off this microphone so that is something
that they're pinning on the Democratic
party in Washington they're not pinning
it on the Republican party that's
controlling the State of Florida hot
damn boy